Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 4th,
2013 what's going on?
How are you?
Congratulations to the Buffalo Ravens.
My condolences to the fans of the San Francisco 40.
Niners.
What a fucking game.
Huh?
What a GS is cheeky.
Can you believe that game?
Why does it sound like I'm in a Tin Cup this week?
Um,
you know,
it's funny,
I actually won money on that.
I totally flipped and bet the Ravens I was sitting there,
uh,
you know,
I remember all this shit I talked about last week about how you watched the game
and this is what you should do and fuck all this and fuck all that,
you know,
let the game go for 90 minutes and all that.
We'll basically half the reason why I was doing that was because,
um,
I was actually working,
on Superbowl Sunday,
the Sunday of the Superbowl Superbowl Sunday.
I'm so fucking sick of that shit.
So I didn't think I was going to see the game anyways.
And by the time I got home,
knee was already gonna be off to a party or whatever and then,
uh,
you know,
I be 90 minutes in or whatever and I could just start it and do everything that
I said I was going to do.
Well,
we wrapped early and all of a sudden I'm driving home and I pull in and I don't
see the car and I'm thinking,
oh shit,
she already left.
Well,
fuck it.
Then I'll just stick with my plan.
And then I walked into the house and then the dog wasn't there and I realized
that she had taken the dog and they went on some hike or something.
Then she comes back and she's like,
oh,
your home.
Well,
do you want to go to the,
you know,
what am I going to say?
No,
no,
fuck you leave,
you go to the party and I'm going to sit here like the old curmudgeon than I am
now.
Pardon me?
Actually wanted to go to a Superbowl party because I was a lady that I got out
of work early.
You know what I mean?
I feel like a kid,
like he had a half day at school and if you're so fucking dumb you forgot you
did.
So I was in more of a social mood,
so I was like,
all right,
fuck it,
I'll go.
But uh,
I didn't have a dog in the fight so I just decided to just say fuck it.
All right.
So I went onto Twitter and I basically,
I wrote a
cause,
you know,
you know what you mean when you're just watching the game,
your team isn't in it.
It's going to be boring.
You've got to get some sort of action on the game.
So it was like,
I don't want to do,
I'm going to talk shit on Twitter and I'm either going to be 100% right or I'm
going to be 100% wrong.
But either way people are going to react to it.
So I just wrote,
Ravens will win f what you think you know?
No that,
I know what you don't shut your face.
Put your money down.
Thank,
thank me later.
That's when I wrote to figure it immediately.
I'm going to get a ton of shit from 49 are fans and people who got shit on the,
on the fucking 49 hours,
you know,
just to add some excitement to the day,
that's my little world.
If I'm not getting trashed on Twitter and I'm sitting,
I'm bored.
So,
um,
then I'm just sitting there.
All right,
so now I've got people yelling at me on Twitter.
Okay,
that's getting the blood going here.
Now what else can I do?
I'm like,
I know.
Fuck this.
I'm texting Versie and Keith Robinson and I just,
I just texted him.
I just wrote,
Ravens will win today.
Okay,
let me see.
I got to show you the shit that I wrote to versa.
He so fucking,
he's so like dejected right now cause you know he loves calling shit.
I texted him,
I'm going to read you these texts right here.
I wrote Ravens when today straight up,
25 bucks.
He writes back,
you're hilarious.
Let's be,
let's be men and go 50.
Just kidding.
25 is cool,
confirmed and I said 50 confirmed and he goes nice.
And he goes,
I think something weird is going to happen.
I don't know what that means,
but something crazy happens in this game.
And then I wrote classic Versie Superbowl prediction.
I got a feel and something weird is going to happen.
That's like bedding,
every number in roulette.
I'm just saying how he's just throwing that out there.
You know I got it.
This,
there's just something's gonna I got a feeling something's going to happen.
Um,
anyway,
so I just wrote capital letters.
Raven's when,
no,
no feeling.
Just the facts.
So then he goes,
Raymond's are not as good.
49 is have better personnel.
I'm saying,
cause I had to get them to commit.
It goes.
I'm saying there's going to be frank,
uh,
of Franco Harris play on this game.
Something nuts happens.
Got a feeling.
Okay.
And he still hit me with the dude.
I called it.
I told you something weird was going to happen.
Oh,
he drives me nuts.
You thought it was going to be human being weird shit.
You didn't think it was going to be the fucking matrix.
Goddamn fucking lights going out.
So anyways,
I said,
take everything you think you know about football.
Take it outside and throw it in the trash.
Joe Flacco coming of age game today,
he'll be one and done.
Just like Trent Dilfer,
perfectly bookending ray Lewis,
his career.
Randy Moss will retire ringless and we'll take it out on a meter maid.
He goes,
no way.
Mohs already said he's coming back.
49 is love him.
He's a model citizen.
Ma Ma's catches TD pass and game today you starting to get stale,
bur you football philosophies getting old.
The game is passing you by parentheses,
Don Shula.
Things Change Dude,
lol.
And I said,
I'll take don shool over B and Jerry Glanville,
you're all talking.
No results.
You couldn't pick a winner if I gave you tomorrow's paper,
you're a bum.
Versie so now we're just talking shit.
All right,
so now he starts naming all the shit that he did back in the day and I'm like,
ah,
you have,
you'll lose so much.
You catch phrases.
I'm back and I'm trashing of where the fuck is this year.
Okay,
submit your retirement papers and begin your broadcasting career.
All.
He actually laughed at that one.
I said,
fuck off.
And then I set my brain and money's say Raven's hearts weren't 40 niners and he
goes,
better teams,
40 nice win this game.
I said,
it's going to be great.
FLACCO's experience might be the difference.
I think Kaepernick is going to throw a pick late in the game.
All right.
And he said Mazda is going to do something.
I said Mohs is like an old super model.
All right?
So the fucking game unfolds.
Every fucking thing that I said is happening and I'm ready to rub it in this
dude's face and then the fucking ravens.
Okay.
The fucking Baltimore Ravens.
Arguably the Domus call in Superbowl history since bill Belicheck went for it on
fourth and eight on the giants,
45 I think,
or something in the first quarter in 2007.
Um,
when they didn't just kick the field goal and they had that stupid rookie,
hey,
run with the fucking ball.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I actually have an all cat.
I'm just gonna read you all my tweets for the game.
All capital letters.
I say dumb has played in super bowl history.
Kicked a field goal.
I couldn't fucking believe it.
Why would you do that?
You know you got your foot on their fucking throat.
Just kick the Goddamn feel.
Go.
Don't give him any hope.
Don't have that fun.
You don't have your kicker
go on her shouldn't even wear uniforms.
They should just go out there and pajamas one slipper in one cleat.
Right.
You sitting there,
everybody out there,
it's got some sort of injury.
You know you've got fucking deer antler juice in your veins just trying to get
through a fucking NFL season and you risk the entire tape fucking season.
Okay.
On,
on a,
a naked bootleg by your fucking kicker.
Oh my God.
I lost my shit at the Super Bowl party by the way.
I went to a great Superbowl party that,
that convinced me that you could watch it in live time.
Cause this dude had one TV for people who wanted to Yap.
And he had another one for everybody.
Shut the fuck up.
We're in the war room was great.
Um,
so anyways.
Okay.
Then what,
how,
what happened?
The 40 niners went down.
I was drinking a Budweiser,
so I'm trying to remember.
They went down and now,
now it's 14 to fucking six and I'm like morons.
And then I texted Rosie.
I said,
by the way,
everything that I said was going to happen has happened.
He goes,
I know it's,
it's killing me.
And then inexplicably,
I dunno what the fucking 40 niners did.
They let a guy go thinking the safety was going to pick him up.
You saw the game.
It's pathetic.
I loved it because I had money on it,
but that was fucking pathetic.
Guy Catches a ball,
falls down,
gets back up.
Keystone cops,
nobody can tackle him.
The guy goes in for a fucking touchdown.
So I write what the fuck.
And then verse,
he just writes Europe.
Accountant.
Okay.
So now I'm loving life because I would Versie on this.
Now I never talked.
I mean I talk shit on the podcast,
but I never before the game say without a doubt somebody is gonna fucking win.
I just felt like doing it just cause I,
I was,
I,
like I said,
my team lost that was going to have any excitement.
So I figured out either be getting trashed or I could trash somebody else,
which is really the greatest thing about talking shit.
So the fucking halftime show,
I mean it's so super bowls,
so fucking ridiculous.
It's like spinal tap at this point.
The fucking pomp and circumstance.
If I'm using that,
that expression correctly,
how all the extra shit that is going on the NBA for as much as they blow their
fans every 20 minutes,
they don't even do that.
You don't have a game seven,
you know,
and then there's,
in the middle of it,
all of a sudden it turns into a fucking Broadway musical.
You just see all those fans like running by.
Yeah,
by the camera doing that.
I know how to dance run or you run with your Chin beyond your fucking toes and
your hands are like drafting behind you.
Ooh,
run out on the fucking grid iron.
Oh,
it's fucking horrific.
And smoke machines and all that shit.
I got to say something.
I love that Beyonce got caught lip syncing because it was great to just see her
just go out and sing the fucking song.
You can sing.
She got a little out of breath a couple of times,
but it worked.
You know
she came out there.
You know what the fucking half our goods hanging out as they all do.
As they say,
hang on.
You know one side of their mouth.
Don't objectify a stop you got,
it's like we're objects.
The facts.
Right.
And then look at them when they can call the shots.
Did they go out?
Do they ever,
do they ever dress elegant?
No,
they don't.
Tits out.
Fucking hoo ha hanging out the he a fucking leather shorts.
You know that dumb ass walk she's doing web who were being weapon web damn
fucking ass cheeks hitting people in the front row.
The fuck are you doing?
But anyways,
that's not my world.
Some people like that.
I thought Alicia keys was really classy.
You know,
she sat there,
she actually had a Jerry Glanville haircut.
Oh is that Wade Phillips?
She was doing something.
She was doing some sort of tribute.
Um,
I'm just fucking with you.
She had a conch,
I think that that's what that was called.
Salt peanuts sell peanuts.
Um,
anyways,
it was a bebop reference with fucking song was that and was way back in the day.
It happened to him.
Let him sell peanuts.
So Penis,
sorry.
Anyways,
plowing ahead.
So then the second half starts and I'm still a little nervous going.
I didn't like that fucking shit.
Right.
They run the ball back first play of the game.
That was another reason why it was done for them not to take the fucking points.
It's like you get the ball back.
Okay.
You getting the ball back to open the second half.
Just take the fucking points.
I swear to God,
John Madden projectile vomited when they fucking roll that thing out.
Puked up like nine Turkey legs.
He's the guy who actually eats a Turkey every year,
by the way.
The thanksgiving Turkey.
All right.
A little known fact.
That's not even a Wikipedia yet.
All right.
Someone has put up there.
Just know that it came from this podcast.
Okay.
All right.
So then they run the fucking ball back and [inaudible] he just goes,
congratulations.
He calls it says games over and I write,
I go to early to worldly.
I hate when a team goes up big like that because then it kind of like,
hey,
let's fucking chill out.
You know,
kick our cleats off.
The other team always seems to come back nowadays.
Right.
And then the fucking power goes out.
Why am I talking to you guys like this?
Like you miss the game.
The fucking power goes out.
Okay.
One of the greatest breaks I've ever seen a team get,
and I know like 49 are friends were like,
well,
you know the ravens got to regroup to,
they didn't need to regroup.
Yeah,
they had you on the ropes live a shot upper cut all the hand,
right.
Fucking your mouth pieces flying in the front row and you get a half hour time
out.
You got another halftime.
Okay.
To get dead.
Zombie.
Holy fucking shell shocked.
Look off your face.
Okay.
By the time the fucking game starts up again.
That was brutal because then he had to listen to more Shannon Sharpe,
who I swear to God,
I don't get that guy at all.
When he was a player,
I could understand every word that he said.
He spoke more clearly before we started broadcasting.
Can anybody explain that?
I'm one of the Broncos beat us and he did that whole funny riff about,
you know,
call the fucking Pentagon because the Patriot missiles,
I forget what I understood every word.
I didn't enjoy it cause he was shitting on my team,
but I can understand them.
And ever since he started announcing,
I can't understand a fucking word that guy say that should be a drinking game.
Okay.
No,
can't be a drinking game cause you don't know me.
Every time he says [inaudible] you got to fucking do a shot.
Okay.
He literally sounds like that job in baby good.
I can't,
I can't understand a fucking word he's saying.
Okay.
And you sit sitting there drunk trying to figure it out.
And he's sitting,
he still lifts too.
So he's bulging out of his pinstripe suit.
[inaudible],
I don't know.
Anyways,
broadcaster broadcaster and you can understand a fucking word you say and it's
unreal on fucking real.
So anyways,
he's back doing his shit and I thought,
by the way,
I thought everybody did a phenomenal job because that nobody knew that that was
coming back and all of a sudden all these guys have to fucking talk for a half
an hour.
And I swear to God if they ever put that Superbowl out on DVD,
I want see the screaming and yelling that was going on in the control room.
You know,
I want to see the whole build,
like the lights go out.
I just wanna hear that.
Well what the fuck's going on?
Okay,
we got a problem here.
If we got prompt with vector vector,
mayday,
whatever fucking military shit that they're using in there till like all the way
to the build where they're like seven excruciating minutes in,
whether it's just some guy and I doing that,
just fucking losing his shit.
Fuck it.
Switch this.
Absolutely.
Or did they keep their cool is beads of sweat.
I just pictured it like NASA with all those guys with like their short sleeve
dress shirts.
You know what to do during an emergency.
You keep,
you stay calm.
You think it was like that or somebody had to have been flipping out
somebody in a suit through a phone,
something happened.
Somebody,
you know what?
I bet whoever really runs the NFL,
he's upstairs in his villa.
He's got one of those long winding staircases.
I bet he came bursting out of a fucking bedroom trying to throw a robot.
You know his real wife downstairs,
a couple of hookers up,
up,
up.
I'll coming down the stairs.
I honey,
what's wrong?
And he just runs right out the fucking front door and his God damn robe dives in
his Bentley and just starts driving to the fucking electric company.
Something happened.
Then he weighs 49 is get a fucking half hour time out to fucking a half hours
standing.
Eight count,
never seen anything like it
and the whole fucking game just turns
unreal.
Fucking unbelievable.
Then all of a sudden they score two quick ones.
The game was,
I ain't never seen a game like it.
Never seen a game like that.
But in the end,
I know and I know a lot of 49 his fans are bitching,
you know,
cause the dude held at receiver and he did hold that receiver.
All right.
But they also gave you guys a do over on a f on that field goal,
that roughing the kicker call was fucking horse shit.
That guy missed it and I swear to God,
Scott Norwood was probably relieved.
Good.
Somebody else they can yell at and then he does that fucking dramatic dive and
he's like,
fuck,
that's what I should have done.
Did you see that?
He kicks the ball.
He's totally threw his whole motion and all that.
And I know you can't touch the kicker at all.
I think that guy grazed his Achilles tendon,
not both of them,
just one and he fucking collapsed.
Like he fainted.
I think he faded.
I don't even think he was hit and they get to do it over.
So I don't know as much as you know,
I think that receive on that receiving play,
whatever that that could have gone either way.
That's one of those borderline,
yes he held him.
But if they gave you first and fucking goal,
you four downs to punch it in,
you couldn't and you got a half hour standing,
eight count and your team went to,
you know,
your team went down 28 to six,
she did it to yourself.
So I dunno,
I'm not trying to fucking give you,
I am actually,
I guess I'm kind of giving you shit,
but I'm not trying to do that because uh,
whatever.
I think the 49 is a great,
I think Catherine Hicks,
the future I tell on you right now.
Joe Flacco is one and done one and done
one and done.
He's got his one ring.
That's it.
And then in the end,
which is great,
good for him.
And in the end when they have this,
they have to like to the reunion of Superbowl winners.
You know when they got the big boy table,
the guys with more than one eli sitting there,
given Tom Brady shit a,
I got you twice a fuck you one three.
Yeah,
but it got you twice.
Don Brady's dimple starts sweating.
You know Terry Bradshaw,
Joe Montana,
this sitting down and the little,
the little table,
the fucking Peyton manning table,
there'll be sitting,
it's fucking goddamn
pencil heads sticking through the ceiling.
Joe Flacco is going to be there.
Take Man's going to be there.
Trent Dilfer is going to be there.
That guy from whoever the fuck quarterback,
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers,
they're all going to be sitting there.
You know,
Len Dawson is going to be sitting there going,
wow,
why did I do shy?
MMM.
I'm just fucking around.
It was an unbelievable game.
And um,
I don't know.
I'm glad I won money.
So then,
okay,
so then the game's over.
So now I won.
So now I got to talk shit.
Right?
So I call up VRC.
If I really been talking about this for 20 minutes,
I fucking,
uh,
I called fuzzy up.
He doesn't pick up and I leave him a message and say that he has a one game
suspension.
He's not allowed to call me for 24 hours because of his awful Superbowl
prediction.
Yeah,
I know I'm a con,
but you know what,
he ended up calling me back and we were laughing about it.
So,
uh,
it's fucking great.
I love it.
I out dude.
I called it Paul Versey.
Is there anything better than that
that just fucking beaten somebody at like what they do?
You know what I mean?
It's like a,
I don't know,
pick somebody catch phrase who says,
oh no you did it.
It's like you say it better than they say it.
Um,
all right.
Advertising for this week everybody.
Hey,
guess what?
Guess what?
Everybody Valentine's Day's coming up
right here.
It's the pressure.
What are you going to do sao?
What are you get your girl fan,
right?
And I know pro flowers,
everybody and press her friends.
Impress your friends.
I love that shutter Fred's up.
Cause they were always there.
Always piping up.
Right?
And press her friends.
Her friends are going to ask.
So what did he get you for Valentine's Day and press your woman and her friends
is probably even more important to impress their friends.
Look at pro flowers.
Just hitting the nail on the head.
Sandra Flowers from pro flowers and shut her friends up.
Um,
anyways,
this is,
this is the easiest thing ever.
You should do it right now.
It's already February 4th.
Okay.
Just have this as your ace in the hole.
You get one.
Doesn't romantic rainbow roses in a free glass vase from uh,
for my buddies here at pro flowers for just 1999.
You know what you do,
dude?
You send it to a work they love that show you love in front of everybody up and
shut up all those other broads and all the other cubicles.
They'll peek over and see it and then sadly,
oh,
so nice.
And then sadly sink back down behind their cubicle wall.
That's what,
you know what?
No woman's going to feel great.
Um,
rub it in their face on Valentine's Day.
anyways,
so for my listeners,
uh,
you get double the roses for nine 99 more.
So you've already got a dozen roses for 20 bucks.
If you want to give her two dozen roses,
doubled down,
split says it's going to cost you less than 30 bucks.
You just need my code.
B U R r a bird.
When you order.
Um,
what am I,
what am I going here?
Okay,
here's the only way to get the amazing Valentine's Day deal.
Call one 800 pro flowers and mentioned bur bur or go to go to proflowers.com
click on the microphone in the top right corner and typing burpee you are are.
That's proflowers.com click on the microphone and type in birth.
Order it today.
Do not procrastinate.
You know what I mean?
Don't let the pressure built just bad.
You do it.
Okay,
and then what did I tell you about the restaurants?
Do you go out on the 14th no,
you do not.
Yeah,
go out on the 15th
yeah.
WHO's out on the 15th nobody.
Nobody.
I'll go out on the 13th who goes out on the 13th nobody.
Go out and enjoy yourself.
Okay.
If you,
your woman's giving you ship.
And I want to do what everybody else does.
Just be,
listen,
I just want to,
I want to be with you and we'll be,
we'll go with the world,
you know,
let's go see a movie.
Let's go to our favorite restaurant and pay what is supposed to cost.
All right,
here's a couple dozen roses for you that I gave to you at work.
Your,
you'll be a champ.
You will be a champ.
Well,
that work and it depended a younger sometimes,
you know,
I want to be part of the thing at least once.
Um,
he voice everybody.
You starting a company and you want to make it sound even better than it already
is.
You want to sound like you got a giant corporation that you're working with.
Make people feel comfortable giving you money,
investing into your project.
Uh,
he voice is what busy professionals use to save time and work smarter.
He voice converts all your voicemails to texts and sends it directly to your
cell phone.
No more interrupting your day to check your voicemail or waiting till after a
meeting to find out what's going on with he voice.
Your calls will always be routed to you,
no matter where you are.
A voice also comes with your own conference line to up to 94 participants on one
single call.
You know,
who could have used that?
The NFL when the power went out,
they definitely could have needed 94 person conference call.
Um,
it all starts for less than $10 per month,
but right now they have a special offer for our podcast.
For My podcast listeners,
uh,
you can get a evil,
he can get eve voice free for six months with no obligation.
You can try it out for free for six months.
What are you waiting for?
Get on with your dreams for CIC for free six months trial.
Go to www dot [inaudible] dot com and at the pro Promo Code Bill B,
I l l for some of my special listeners,
um,
he voice can make your small business sound professional like a fortune 500
company.
They can create your own custom professional greetings.
There's like nine zillion options that you can have this.
And one of my favorite thing is they actually have voiceover actors.
So you can actually sound like you have this hot chick from frigging London or
something.
Damn.
Hello.
Have all,
yeah,
thank you for calling.
Applecart.
Whatever the hell you going to call your company.
You get it,
you get the deal.
All right,
please do it.
Please get out of your cubicle.
Um,
all right,
back to the podcast.
So anyways,
I watched a bunch of,
uh,
I watched a bunch of crazy shit this week.
You know,
I finally,
I got the center ice package and I've been loving life.
This,
you know,
it's underrated.
The sport you love going on strike for half a season and then trying to cram as
many games in as they possibly can for the rest of the season.
As a fan,
you love in life,
back to back nights.
My Bruins are on for them.
It sucks.
You know,
they life stinks.
My life is a fan where I have to sit there and not exert myself other than
walking back and forth to the fridge is tremendous.
Um,
been watching the Bruins all week.
We've been playing great,
except when we played the savers,
they made us look like fools,
man.
They won like every facet of the game.
And they even won the fight.
And Sean Thornton fought this guy,
John Scott,
and he got a concussion,
was brutal because I love Sean Thornton because even though he's an,
he's an enforcer,
he's not,
he's not a dirty player.
He's one of those guys,
if he knocked shut down and you're on your way down to the ice,
he doesn't throw that extra one,
you know?
And uh,
so when he was,
he fights this guy and the guy,
he's basically rain in punches down on them.
It's the,
most of them are hidden his helmet and he's fine until the end.
He takes his brutal upper cut.
So I looked at,
I looked it up.
Sean Thornton is six,
two,
two 20.
He fights this guy,
John Scott,
the guy,
six,
eight to 70.
He's given away half a foot in 50 pounds.
And I'm just like these guys,
it's no wonder,
I remember like reading this stuff,
you know,
like when you know Boogaard died and everything and they start talking about the
uh,
you know,
the,
the concussions and all the shit that these guys get any,
I don't know,
as a hockey fan and you just don't,
for some reason you just don't think about it.
Cause he enforces like a superhero.
He's like the guy you always wanted to be like guy who will fight anybody,
you know,
not scared of anything.
You know,
you kind of like live vicariously through them if you're like a pussy like me,
you know.
So I just started looking at these,
these guys up,
the top fighter last year in the Nhl had 20 fights,
20 fights.
The season is six months long for four weeks in a month.
That's 24 weeks.
This guy had 20 bare knuckle fist fights.
I mean that,
that's,
that's fucking unreal.
That's half a boxer's career career in six months.
I don't believe these.
They're like,
that's just a whole other level of tough.
Think about like somebody you went to high school with who did do,
didn't give a fuck and he would,
he would throw down with anybody.
Did he have 20 fights in the entire time?
You know him
and if he did,
how many years was that?
Did He have 20 fights?
Nobody has 20 fights in six months.
Go fuck yourself for everybody.
You email,
dude,
I know this guy.
Yeah,
I don't believe it.
I want to see the video.
I don't know.
That's just one of those.
There's a few things,
right?
I think all guys,
you try to pretend you're tougher than you are,
but then there's a few things that you see.
You just see something like that and you just realize like,
I am a fucking,
I should be walking around wearing a dress.
And then that guy,
John Scott actually said he was,
he was legitimately concerned going,
you know,
yeah,
we fought,
but I,
I,
I felt bad.
He didn't come back.
You don't want to hurt anybody.
Like those are the true tough guys that just go out and,
and do the job.
They don't try to be dirty or any of that type of Shit,
you know?
Um,
but I watched a couple of things this week that got my ego in check and one of
them was watching Sean Thornton fight.
John Scott Watch when he does it too.
It's like he realizes the guys half a foot taller and 50 pounds more when they
dropped the,
they're dropping the gloves in.
Thorton is already reaching to grab him to somehow get inside where it's just
like,
I do not want to be,
if this guy can extend his arm and I'm going to take this punch from the
stratosphere,
I just can't imagine what that's like lining up next to a mountain gone.
This is my job.
I have to fight this guy.
And you don't even get like gloves to at least protect your hands,
you know?
Ugh.
Anyways,
so I saw that and like my ego wasn't already enough in check.
Um,
I then watched this thing about the most dangerous criminals,
any penal system,
whatever the fuck they call it.
And they interviewed
for maniacs.
Okay.
Three of all white dudes.
And I swear to God,
when white dude's become maniacs,
you know,
I don't want to talk shit,
but I really think that we,
we really do it better than anybody else.
When a fucking white dude goes rogue,
a lot of people are going to get hurt.
I'm telling you
that Hannibal,
like when a real life,
Hannibal Lecter comes along and I know a bunch of def jam comics,
I've done a bit about this,
but it really is true.
You know,
Melina,
the classic Def Jam bit,
if somebody,
whatever,
shoot somebody stabbed somebody or whatever,
that could be a black guy,
Latino guy.
But if somebody,
after they shoot him,
stab him and then they fucking make a fucking ear sandwich or something,
you know,
chop off the guy's hand and stick the guy's ear in between it and just munch on
it.
When the cops show up and they're sitting there with their feet on the coffee
table,
like,
hey officer,
that's going to be a white guy.
So there's showing,
yeah,
whatever they pick.
Like I wish I remember what channel was on.
Okay.
They showed for the biggest fucking maniacs.
Oh,
you know what?
I watched it online.
Okay.
Did I watch it online?
Yeah,
I did.
I did watch it online.
I'll,
I'll get the clip for you.
So I watched this thing and
okay.
They had this fucking one white dude.
He was hilarious because he was really like,
he was at scariest kind of evil where he was.
Uh,
there's two kinds of scary evil.
There's that one where you're,
you're off like border line.
Like,
I don't even know if you've got a complete brain and what,
you almost have like a reptilian brain and you're acting literally like a
fucking Komodo Dragon.
Like you just don't give a shit,
you know?
Yeah.
But you have see like a reptile eat something.
Like it could give a fuck if a reptile ever fucks with the mammal.
A mammal is going through the emotions.
And I got ah,
screaming in pain and the reptile is just,
just sitting there with this blank look on his face as it slowly swallowing,
swallowing the fucking mammal hall.
Um,
even when snakes fucking eat other snakes,
the snakes,
this getting eaten,
it's just kind of go on this fucking,
it doesn't really give a fuck.
It never lose.
I mean,
it still has sort of a fierce look on its fate.
If did I just say fierce?
Like it's a fucking Broadway dancer,
like a ferocious look on his face,
but they never like,
reptiles never have that,
you know?
Oh my God.
Like they,
they don't,
they don't have that.
They just don't have that emotion.
They just either sitting there going,
God damn,
it's cold out.
I got to get in the sun.
Or they're like,
I'm going to fucking kill you.
I just bit you and I'm going to just wait till the,
the I'm gonna slowly choke you out.
They just don't give a fuck.
We get it,
Bill.
We've seen the animal channel.
All right.
Whatever.
So
yeah,
these psychos,
they're either like that or they're even worse.
Did just like super intelligent and they're completely aware of what they're
doing and they just don't give a shit.
And that was the guy that I saw.
I saw this,
this white dude,
right?
Shaved head,
tattoos right up to his fucking Adam's apple and he's got a couple of fucking,
you know,
okay.
Little Wayne Shits on his face,
right?
Just a couple of those,
you know,
and uh,
he's sitting and he has this look of like,
um,
you would've thought rolling stone was interviewing him about an album that he
was really proud of and he knew that this was the one that was,
he was going to make his mark,
you know,
when he was just sitting in this fucking cage
and this woman is interviewing him and she's talking,
you know,
he got arrested for murder,
he's on trial for murder and he did the shit.
He knows he's going to get convicted.
So he goes into jail and he's not scared.
He fucking embraces it.
He decides that he's just going to become this warrior that he's been put on
this planet to become a fucking warrior.
So we start to reading all those books,
the art of war and all his shit,
and he immediately,
while he's waiting to go on trial,
joins a gang.
Okay.
And one of the things he had to do
to,
to get into the gang was he had to kill somebody.
So for some reason to see his cell mate,
they wanted this guy dead.
Okay.
So I forget,
I can't remember how the fuck this guy's story was.
So fucking mind blowing.
He fucking
just brutalize this guy beyond like recognition,
like they couldn't eat,
the guy was missing one of his eyeballs,
they couldn't even find it.
And then in the end,
after he kills the fucking guy,
he shuts up his cooktop on top of them,
use them as like a table in like made himself like a fucking egg mcmuffin or
something fucking crazy like that.
So he's telling the story and he's Kinda got this half smile on his face and he
goes in,
here's the ironic thing.
He goes,
no.
he goes,
I go to my trial and he goes,
and I get it,
quit it.
He gets,
and he goes,
and that's when he smiled and he goes,
he goes,
yeah.
The irony of it was just that I,
it was just ridiculous.
Like
he was laughing at it.
Like,
I can't even,
I
like he was sitting there going on,
you know,
I fucking,
put a raincoat on a bubble out,
all this type of shit.
I come outside in the sunshine.
I mean the irony of it was it was ridiculous.
He's fucking cook cooking on top of a guy that he just murdered.
Just sitting there like yeah,
whatever.
And then he gets fucking acquitted.
So then she,
so that's when he like truly just embraces like he got 79 years for what the
fuck he did do his cellmate.
Cause I think at that point they were just going like,
all right,
not only did you do that,
you probably did this other shift that we just acquitted.
You have.
So now he's in there and he's in this gang and he's talking about
prison life and just having like a shank and all that type of thing.
And he's just was literally,
he was like fascinated the same way.
I'm fascinated when I watch a football game,
how the momentum can shift.
He was talking about prison life like that.
Like,
how quickly it can shift and why you have to have a shank.
Because you know,
everything can be cool,
everything's great.
And all of a sudden somebody getting stuck like 9 million fucking times and he
said something to the effect of a,
you know,
I've seen it,
I've done it.
He's just sitting there just proud.
Then they went to two other fucking crazy white dudes.
One guy was just sitting there going,
just talking about a,
you know,
I just really enjoy hurting people.
You got to see this fucking video.
And I didn't even get to the black dude.
The black dude was in the end.
And uh,
I didn't read it,
but they said that I saw some of the comments under the youtube videos said that
last black guy let the black dude's shouldn't have been in there cause he seemed
like he was bipolar.
So I didn't get to the crazy guy.
There's always the one fucking crazy dude.
But,
uh,
hopefully I'll be able to get you guys this video.
But it's one of those things where,
um,
okay.
You know,
for basically for guys,
one of your number one fears in life is what if I get arrested for some shit I
didn't do and I go to jail?
How do I prevent myself from getting raped?
You know?
And if you don't watch one of these behind the scene prison things,
you can lie to yourself.
I do this,
I do that.
You can have your little fucking Kung Fu fantasy and you fucking head.
I'm speaking for everybody.
That was,
this is me.
Anyways,
that's what I do.
But the second I ever watch any of those prison fucking things,
I just,
you know,
I would not less,
I would not last three seconds in prison.
Not like you didn't already know that.
I guess this is more for me.
I once again was slapped down to the reality of who the fuck I really go.
But I'll definitely get those videos for you.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Am I a chatty Cathy this week?
38 fucking minutes and I haven't got to your questions.
All right,
let's do some more fucking,
uh,
some copy here.
What do we got here?
Legal.
Zoom.
Everybody.
Alright?
He waiting for the perfect time to start your dream business.
It's now all right.
You will as you know what,
let me just get to the point that she want it.
You want to get,
you know,
you want to start a business,
you want to be legal and all that type of thing,
but you want to get through all the rigmarole.
If I can use that as quickly as possible because you like me and you have add
and you don't want to deal with any of that crap legal zooms where you want to
go.
All right.
See an official sponsor of national start ups.
It's,
yeah.
If National Start Your business month and legal zoom wants you to get started,
right?
Whether you're starting up an ls LLC,
s Corp Sole Proprietor to ship or nonprofit legal zones takes care of you from
start to finish.
They're award winning service was developed by the best legal minds in the
country and every business gets personalized attention.
That's why over 90% of legal zoom customers would recommend the service to their
family.
You'll be in good company.
Over two dozen companies on the INC 500 list.
We're started through legal zoom.com.
Think about that.
The top 500 businesses,
uh,
or started a legal zoom.com.
It says national.
It's national starch your business month.
So Start Your business right@legalzoom.com.
Legalzoom is not a law firm and provide self health services at your specific
direction,
but there's so much more now,
every LLC and incorporation package includes easy to use business accounting
software or $269 value for free.
Be sure to enter burpee,
you rr and the referral box at checkout.
Start Your Business,
protect your family and safeguard your assets@legalzoom.com today.
And lastly,
stamps.com everybody.
All right.
If you haven't,
if you don't listen to this every week and you're still going to the post office
dog gone it.
I'm here to help.
Um,
if you haven't heard yet,
postage rates have changed again.
You know what that means?
The post office will be even more crowded than usual.
Everybody going down there to get there,
two and a half cent stamp to add to the other one and all that crap.
That's why you need stamps.com stamps.com makes it easy for you to not have to
go to the post office ever again.
Everything you would do with the post office you can do right at your desk.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter or package using your own
computer and printer and stance.
Dotcom always updates the postage rates for you automatically so you will always
get the exact postage you need the instant you need it.
You never have to go to the post office again.
It's a dream.
All right.
I've been using stamps.com for uh,
almost a year now.
Sending my DVDs out to the clubs.
I've had zero problems and I don't have to stand in line at the post office.
It's awesome.
Right now,
use my name Burb Borr for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus.
It includes a digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
birth.
All right,
let's get to your,
uh,
let's get to your questions for the week here.
Or anybody see that?
Montreal Canadiens auto as senator game.
That was some old school refereeing.
They used to happen all the time back in the day.
Not so much anymore.
That was classic.
Automatize the game up to two.
All of a sudden the refs wave it off.
No gold goalie interference.
You know,
and I know what people are saying.
Well,
what about the goalie interference in the Bruins?
Toronto game?
I'll tell you this,
at least to go,
Ross got hit.
He was outside of the crease.
Bad call.
Bad call should not have been a disallowed goal.
Hundred percent agree with maple leaf fans,
but come on maple leaf fans.
I know you hate the Canadians too.
You got to admit at least w Ross got fucking hit fucking Canadians goalie.
Nobody even touched him.
Classic put them on the power play.
Third period of any Montreal game.
The entire time I was growing up.
Two minutes.
Goalie interference.
Too many men on the boarding four minute power play for the French cunts.
Um,
anyways,
and of course the hang on to when I actually liked what Montreal is doing
though.
I like that they have a bunch of young players and that young kid,
one of the young kids that they kept up after the five game trail,
he had a couple of assists the other night,
you know,
when they beat the
hell did they play when they,
they beat him,
the Sabres who embarrassed the Bruins.
So Hey,
if you're not,
if you're not into a hockey and you want to get into an Bruins Canadians
Wednesday night,
all right.
It's always,
it's always a great one.
You never know who's going to win.
The bad blood goes all the way back to pre,
uh,
the depression.
Okay.
All right,
here we go.
Let's get to the questions for this week.
Herpes and the girl of my dreams.
Um,
I am 27 and about four months ago I met the girl of my dreams.
Congratulations.
She is hot,
smart,
funny,
and has a great career.
We went on four dates.
It seemed like she was really into me and we got along great.
Unfortunately,
after our fourth date,
I stupidly slept with a skank.
I met at the bar and caught herpes.
Oh my God,
Dude.
Uh,
Jesus,
I've always been careful to use condoms,
but that night I was too drunk to keep one on.
I became very sick and immediately called the girl of my dreams and told her
that I couldn't see her anymore without my explanation.
Ny and both physically and mentally better.
But I believe she has a boyfriend.
My question is whether I should re pursue a relationship with this girl or just
move on and hope I find another one like her.
Also,
if I do,
should I explain how and when I got herpes,
if she becomes the mother of my children,
I think I would feel guilty if I didn't.
Um,
yeah,
dude,
if you want to get it back,
he uh,
you know,
uh,
we'll do,
did you already sleep with her?
See,
this is what happens when you live.
You just,
if you try and be like,
well,
if you're not going to own up to that shit,
I know all the women right now are screaming,
all the women are screaming,
which is fair because if a woman wrote this,
I would be like,
yeah,
that's your fault to sleeping with that dirty dick.
Um,
you got,
yeah,
dude,
you got to totally come clean.
You've got to tell her exactly what happens,
you know,
and uh,
oh Jesus,
dude.
You know,
I can't judge it either because you know,
every guy has gone out and done that.
That whole scenario fucked around,
not used a condom except you,
you had the bad luck dude.
Oh my God.
As fucking brutal.
Uh,
Jesus.
Well there you go.
People,
they have theirs.
If that doesn't convince you to wear a condom and not sleep with a skank cause I
even heard it,
you know,
even if you wear a condom,
I,
I don't know.
They say you can still get,
it's fucking terrifying.
Fucking terrifying.
How I never stepped on that landmine is beyond me.
So,
dude,
what if you really want to get this girl back?
You know,
every great relationship starts with 100% honesty.
And I'm not going to lie to you.
I think,
you know,
dude,
you're,
that's a hell of a whole to try and crawl out of,
no pun intended.
Um,
but,
uh,
but from here on out,
man,
you gotta you can't do what that skank did to you.
You gotta be honest with people.
Uh,
yeah,
I do.
That's,
that's brutal.
That's brutal.
But you know what?
It's not the end of the fucking world.
Jesus Christ.
But yeah,
you got,
you gotta come with where with with total honesty,
total honesty and a,
yeah.
Turn it in and turn it into a positive dude.
You know,
you're being a fucking dirty dog.
Now I'm telling you,
I believe though,
if you come with total honesty and you,
you,
you stay on a righteous path,
that you will meet that person.
If it's not this one at,
uh,
you know,
who knows?
I don't know.
I'm not trying,
I'm trying not to use a cliche that everything happens for a reason.
Um,
I don't believe that.
And I think,
you know,
you fucked up and now you're paying the price and uh,
you got to try to turn the ship around.
So,
uh,
good luck with that.
But like I said,
I would go with 100% honesty.
You got to,
you can't do that to her.
I can't do that to her.
Um,
all right,
advice from Japan.
Uh,
Bill,
I'm 28 single and I live in Japan.
I'm originally from America,
America and I moved here after college.
I'm a translator and speak decent Japanese.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
how the fuck did you learn that?
You know,
I listen to French,
Spanish,
like that type of shit,
Italian that that seems like,
you know,
you'd get a handle on it,
but that's a pack.
I'm foul.
How to fucking jump on that shit is beyond me.
How they,
how they can go from there.
It's just be able to speak ours.
I swear to God.
It's incredible.
Um,
anyways,
when people ask why I say that I love Japanese people and I love living here,
um,
what
to make it better.
I'm a translator and I speak decent Japanese,
but the culture barrier is still pretty huge for me.
When people ask why.
Okay,
there we go.
I say that I love Japanese people and I love living here,
but I wouldn't ever want to become Japanese.
Generally speaking,
they're overworked and unhappy for better or worse.
My attitude keeps me a little isolated.
Yeah,
I've seen that stuff over there like as far as what I've seen.
Um,
you know,
the propaganda from what I've seen,
I saw on 60 minutes that if you fuck up at your job,
they send you some camp and then you have to sing the company song.
And these guys were singing the song trying to get back into the company.
They like crying and everything and there's like for Japanese dude's just
looking at him,
just ice cold.
Simon cobbles to the fucking nine thousands power,
like your family disowns you,
it's crazy.
It's hardcore over there,
man.
Straightening the dam rivers.
Uh,
there is one very Japanese woman.
What does that mean?
I've met who I recently connected with.
In spite of all that.
She's an amateur artists and actress and we've worked together to make subtitles
for local independent movies.
That's how we met actually.
She's interesting as hell and downright sexy to problems.
She's married and has his son.
Dude,
what the fuck?
Oh,
are you trying to get a fucking Samurai's sword to your juggler?
You're going to fuck a married broad with a kid in a different country,
do it.
I don't.
I don't know anything about the Japanese culture.
But if you can lose face for not having enough paperclips at your God damn desk
and get sent to a borderline death camp and you've got to sing a fucking song to
get back into the company,
how much face do you lose if round?
I fucks your fucking woman though.
You're,
you're gonna,
you're gonna get thrown into one of their straightened rivers.
I,
come on,
man.
Come on man.
Don't do this.
He said from early on it was obvious that there was a mutual attraction going
on,
especially whenever we were at a movie party with a of drinks in us.
Like any guy would.
I wanted to sleep with her,
but I didn't dwell on it.
Good for you.
It seemed,
it never seemed like it was in the cards,
but we were working together.
We kept each other at,
Oh,
when we working together,
we kept each other at arm's length.
Months went by without anything changing.
Oh my God,
Dude.
This is like watching this.
This is like a suspense thriller.
Dude.
You can't do this.
There's a kid involved.
That kid loves his mom and his dad.
You're going to go in there and your Dick like a Samurai sword is going to slice
that kid's life and half he can't do it.
I want to read the rest of this.
Of one eye closed then came the local film festival.
Oh geesh.
When it finished,
we were downtown and pleasantly drunk.
Okay,
and the last trains that run every night,
we're long gone.
Well,
isn't that convenient?
When she mentioned taking an expensive cab ride home,
I suggested that she crashed at my nearby apartment until the morning train
started.
No,
you didn't.
You didn't suggest that you dick did your decks like relax,
stand down.
I've got this.
Anyways,
she had been there a dozen times already because that's where we always worked.
Oh my God dude.
This is like some red shoe diary going on here.
I'll cut to the chase
in my apartment that night.
She turned to me and asked point blank if I wanted to fuck.
Okay.
Wow.
Dude.
At that point I think all bets are off.
Okay.
Cause I thought you were kind of seduced in this girl.
Now she just like,
okay.
Oh Jesus.
Well maybe you should have,
wow,
I didn't see that comment.
Yeah.
Anyways,
he goes and I told her no.
Okay,
okay.
He goes,
I wasn't exactly surprised that she asked.
Part of me was hoping she would when she did though all I could do was go
through what I felt right at that moment.
I admit I really didn't know what to do and was playing it safe.
We went to sleep and she left in the morning.
Here's the thing,
she and her husband who I've never met,
thank God,
don't get along.
Okay.
Oh,
she and her husband don't get along and have no sex whatsoever.
so she's in a loveless marriage.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
This is what she told me anyway.
She has long wanted a divorce but won't do it because of her son.
So while saying no,
might have seemed like the noble non home record thing to do.
Pardon me?
Kept,
keeps asking.
What difference does it make?
Uh,
you know what?
UBC scarf race when the cop goes,
it's your tree frank.
Yes.
Sitting in it.
All right.
That's her fucking situation.
She married a guy that she didn't love and she had a kid.
All right.
You know,
that's your stepping into the world of her bad decision.
Now think back when you were a kid and you thought about meeting the woman,
your dreams.
Is that the way it went down?
I'm not trying to shit on this thing here,
but like,
you know,
I think she needs to be free and clear.
If you were actually thinking of getting into a fucking relationship with this
person.
MMM.
Just thinking about banging her.
I don't know,
Dude.
I don't know this fucking kid.
Look if there was no kid involved,
have at it.
But there's just something,
there's some kids sitting at home in some racing car bed,
you know love and his mom and his dad.
I Dunno,
I dunno.
That's,
do you really want that on your resume anyway,
cause he goes,
then there's the fact that our friendships suffered anyways because ever since
that night she scaled back all the contact with me.
They say that affairs never end well,
but this isn't any,
well either.
I don't know.
I just feel like maybe I should have fucked her now.
If you've trusted guy friends say they would have,
of course they would've.
I would've.
I know I would have if I was drunk and she said that I don't put the kid.
I don't know if I could have blocked out the kid.
I am a piece of shit,
but I don't,
I don't think I'm that big a piece of shit.
I'm just being honest.
All right.
I know there's a lot of ladies that are listening to this thing,
but you know how we are.
Okay.
You lead us around by our fucking Dick.
Some fucking hottie you're working with,
he's probably all you rub one out 50 times to her finally just says,
Hey,
you,
you won't fuck a wood.
I mean,
you're going to do it,
you know,
game on.
MMM.
You know,
the,
you know,
for any woman,
he gets mad at me.
That's some of the most honest shit about men.
You're ever going to fucking here.
So go fuck yourself in your email that you send me.
Okay.
God bless you.
Uh,
my few trusted guy friends say they would have a whatever.
She may sound like,
I think a lot of this woman,
and I've never had someone like her just throw herself at me before.
I'm starting to feel like I missed the boat.
Then again,
she's fucking married and has a kid.
What would he view had done?
I told you what I would have done if she was single.
I remember she was married and didn't have a kid and she was in this loveless
fucking thing.
And every day next to her working together.
She's in my apartment,
comes over smelling good,
and I have a couple of fucking drinks in me and she says he won't fuck,
would for some reason has a southern accent.
I'm all over it.
I would have felt like shit immediately.
I would have felt guilty,
but I'm fucking week.
All right,
I'm a guy,
I'm a fucking moron and it would have been the wrong thing to do.
So you did the fucking right thing.
You did the fucking right to do it.
I'll tell you right now,
you know what?
Go Rub one out tour.
What do you feel like
afterwards?
Do you still feel you not,
you're kind of relieved like,
thank God I didn't do it.
You know,
I dunno.
I just feel bad for her.
You know she married the wrong guy.
She's got a kid with them and then she's fucking says,
Hey,
do you want to bang me a what?
And you're like,
no.
And she's guest.
If you're walking back on,
what the fuck is wrong with my thing?
You know,
why is it my light Saber working here?
I got this power and it's not fucking,
it's not,
it's not happening for me.
Um,
okay.
I Dunno.
I can tell you how to get that train back on the tracks,
but I don't want to do that to you.
So,
uh,
don't,
don't do it,
dude.
There's a kid involved.
Okay.
Even I have standards.
You got to have some sort of standards.
All right?
We just shout your Dick back into your pants.
Like
I said,
stay the fuck down.
You know,
you got to have some sort of something.
All right,
look,
okay.
She's eventually going to leave that guy.
She is,
but I'm telling you,
dude,
that's,
that's not your fucking,
get the fuck out of there.
All right.
Get out of there.
What do we got here?
57 minutes in.
Here we go.
Sticking it to the X.
Should I all right,
right out of the gate I could tell you no,
but let me hear the story.
I'm 28 and I found out about you and move up,
up,
up above or I,
I'm going to get right to it.
My ex wife and I had been together for about five years before we decided to get
married right after university.
Her family was religious so we couldn't live together first,
so that seemed like the next step
as a new Grad was working hard,
trying to get work in my field and basically starting at the bottom,
but slowly getting my footing.
She was working at the same bank she had since high school and through
university and it was filing,
moving up the ranks.
Fast forward a year and a half into our marriage and she's getting promoted to
manager to manage your bank downtown.
She gets a good raise and things are looking good for me or so I thought.
Then a week after she starts this job,
she lays it on me.
Okay.
She wants to know what it's like to be single again.
She never really wanted to get married and apparently she feels that the spark
isn't there anymore.
There is no other guy,
but she just doesn't like who I am anymore and there was nothing in the six
years of us being together worth saving.
Oh Jesus.
Well,
listen,
Kudos to her for being fucking honest and not wasting another five years of your
life.
Okay,
so he goes after.
So after some self reflection and a bit of counseling,
a bit of boozing with friends and an amazingly insightful mushroom trip,
I realized this is a blessing in disguise.
She doesn't like who I am anymore.
Like there was something wrong with me other than taking a shit and being
committed to her for almost six years.
Okay,
this is understandable anger.
I get it.
Get it out of you.
He says,
fuck her.
We had no kids,
not many assets at this point.
A dog that I get.
It was a get out of jail card,
a guilt freeway,
a guilt free way,
clean.
What a guilt free way,
clean way to get out from under the hood of an oppressive.
Can't have a wife who had turned me into a shadow of my former self content with
being fucked.
Maybe once a month we both move out and put our place for our place up for sale.
All right.
No it doesn't.
I don't think that this guy really feels that this woman has a cunt.
He's just saying this cause she fucking dumped him and he goes,
I immediately gave myself a no contact policy,
blocked her on Facebook and you could only talk about business with her until we
got through the separation negotiations in June.
They go,
it's a strong move.
I like it.
Then silence.
The other policy I gave myself was to say yes to any opportunity that was
presented.
This helped me make this past summer the best of my life.
Full of trips and sleeping with new girls,
hotter and younger than her.
Older and uglier.
It didn't matter.
I was saying yes.
Well for the love of God,
wear a condom,
sir.
Um,
even after finding out from one of her friends a few months later that she had
been dating slash living with this guy she had worked with since about a month
after she left me.
Yeah.
This girl is like a,
she goes from relationship to relationship.
Anyways,
he said,
I didn't break the no content policy.
I didn't want her to think I gave two shits about her anymore.
This guy,
by the way,
I had met on many occasions at work functions and even when it came,
okay,
came out for her birthday that year.
I fucking told her that this dude is into you.
I don't like him,
but she would say,
oh,
he's just a friend.
He's a fucking snake in the grass.
Oh,
this guy,
he's like so angry.
He's not even writing in complete sentences and he's his fucking snake
in the grass,
but she's a whore.
I'm not an idiot.
So I can guess that this wasn't just a lucky coincidence.
They both happened to be singled together and likely why things move so fast
regardless.
I kept to my policy now almost a year later,
I'm in the best shape of my life after losing 40 pounds.
Good for you,
man.
Good for you.
This is great.
Just starting a new job where I make as much as her and in my field have a
hotter girlfriend and have one.
All the mutual friends we had there were worth keeping.
So why do you need revenge?
He goes,
all is good,
but I've been feeling like a bit of a bitch for not taking her to task on all of
this shit,
especially now that we've been separated for almost a year and soon can be
legally divorced in Canada.
I think it's time to finally confront her and break her,
so I would like to take this bitch down and my advice on how to go about it
would be great.
Sorry about the length and thanks for any help,
dude.
You're already taken her down.
They say the the greatest revenge is a life well lived.
You're doing it.
You lost 40 pounds.
You have a hotter girlfriend.
Just keep saying yes.
I go easy with the sleeping around.
Dude,
you don't want to catch anything man,
but you know,
just go live your life.
Leave her in the dust.
Okay?
She's going to check out your Facebook page.
She'll see your pictures.
You really want to get back at this girl.
Don't ever talk to her again and just live this awesome life.
Marry a beautiful woman.
Keep yourself in great shape and just know every once in a while she's going to
check in and I guaran fucking tee you.
Unless this guy,
they just had this ridiculous spark at work.
Then God bless them.
She,
she found who she should have been with as will you and it's all good.
Or Jesus serial.
What monogamous.
Whatever the fuck it is.
I'm so dumb.
She goes from relationship to relationship and eventually this dickhead snake in
the grass bank is gonna um,
get the same speech or he might give it to her.
He might be one of these creeps that it turned around that he's in a relation,
that she's in a relationship and he can be fucking banging this chick,
you know,
fuck them.
Fuck them with their,
their bank or sex.
They probably have to wear masks.
You know,
they have some sort of ritual.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
dude,
don't do that.
Don't do that because you know what you're doing when you walk up to her and you
fucking go,
let me tell you something.
You fucking cunt.
The blahblahblahblahblah women are too smart for that shit.
She just sitting there going like,
wow,
he's still does care.
Wow.
He lost that weight because of me.
Not because he's actually a better person than I thought he was.
All right,
don't do that.
She wins.
If you confront her,
she fucking wins.
Just keep doing what you're doing.
Yelling at her like she's in the room,
but she isn't screaming your windshield.
Okay.
But keeps saying yes in life.
Keep going after your dreams and just live this fucking awesome life.
And maybe one day,
who knows?
You go to the same mall,
you show up with your hot wife and two beautiful kids.
She shows up.
She's fat.
You know,
they give you like,
just give her a nod,
a switch.
You could have been with Johnny six pack over here.
Oh,
and you just keep going.
You take your kids for an ice cream when you get yourself a Sherbert.
Um,
all right,
this is one.
Um,
you guys great this week.
Great questions.
Um,
okay.
Here we go.
Last one.
Racism in a relationship or old geezers um,
oh,
she,
she says questions for you.
And the lovely Nia.
If she's there,
oh fuck,
she isn't here.
My boyfriend of a month told me that his mom is racist and his grandpa is
racist,
to the point where he,
he would disown my boyfriend.
Uh,
he says he's not racist,
but he shrugs off family comments and is very nonconfrontational.
I'm not fully black.
Um,
I like to call.
I'm like,
what I,
what I like to call half African.
Uh,
my mom is from Kenya.
My Dad is French Canadian.
I live in Canada,
so I'm not used to racism.
In fact,
I'm so confused when somebody calls me the n word.
I can't help but think my families from Africa,
they should use
the term.
Oh yeah,
I've heard of that term,
which I'm not going to do.
I'm not going to say it to my podcast because that's just going to give more
runs,
you know?
I don't know.
They'll probably figure it out what it is,
but they're not gonna learn it from me anyways.
Um,
he says,
I'm so stupid when it comes to people being racist towards me.
I don't even know how I'm supposed to react.
Obviously I'm hurt and I'm sure there's some obligation I have to stand on
behalf of the belittlement of society.
But what do I say it?
What?
Wait,
when we read that more,
I'm sure there's some obligation.
I have to take a stand on behalf of the betterment of society.
But what do I say to him or his family?
I don't know what I should do.
My boyfriend is worth fighting for,
but family is irreplaceable and I don't want to rip his apart because he,
his needs to be there for him.
If I can't.
Thanks.
Um,
ah,
I don't,
yeah,
he would like to think that he would step up there.
I don't look,
when it comes to your grandparents,
what are you going to do?
You're going to change 80 years.
They are how they are.
You know about your parents.
That's,
that's a a harder issue.
MMM.
Which obviously could grow into a bigger issue if you get even more serious.
I Dunno.
I think that you should be somebody with somebody who has your fucking back.
And I think you need to sit down with him and tell him that he needs to have you
back.
And that is parents need to accept who the fuck he's dating or raw.
You're going to move on and get with somebody who's more of a fucking man and
kin.
You know that if you're with somebody,
they gotta be with you.
Okay?
He is in an awkward position,
but he needs to sit down and have a talk with his parents,
his grandparents that,
that's a fucking wash.
You know what I mean?
Old People always bitch and that bitch in about everything.
So,
you know,
whatever.
Um,
I mean,
grandparents came up in a time where if you were Irish and she was Italian,
they would flip out,
do a Protestant and this person was Catholic.
Like they,
they would separating to that level.
Um,
but yeah,
I think,
uh,
I think you need to have a talk with them,
you know?
And if that ends it and he goes his separate way,
then you know what you got off easy because eventually what it come to a head
and you wouldn't have been happy.
All right?
Regardless of whether it's a race issue or whatever,
the person you're with has to have you fucking back on the big ship.
Okay.
The little stuff about doing dishes and arguing about that,
that's just crap that you argue about.
But something like that is,
I mean,
that's the whole thing.
Holding the fucking thing together.
If that,
that's the foundation.
If that's not there,
then you're wasting your time and you only get one life and you shouldn't be
wasting fucking time.
So that's my advice.
All right.
And that is the podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody for listening.
And uh,
now the weird sadness of football is over.
The stunned that Monday you wake up,
you know,
and it's fucking over.
There is not a game.
Next week is brutal.
So my suggestion this week get into NBA hoop or the NHL.
And if you want to get into the NHL,
I cannot recommend the,
uh,
the NHL Center ice package enough.
Pick a team,
you know,
learn all their players and that type of shit.
It's a fucking beautiful game.
And I'm so happy it's back.
And I,
I'm telling you,
Canadians,
Bruins,
even when both those teams suck,
it's always a great game and neither team sucks right now.
Canadians are playing great.
They're there,
they're rebuilding their team,
they got all this young talent and uh,
the Bruins are,
the Bruins were playing great ourselves other than,
than that fucking game against this same,
um,
whatever.
Pull up a chair,
watch a game,
and right,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a great week.
I'll talk to you later.